devil fruits are one of the most
fascinating and exciting elements in the
one piece universe their mysterious
essence grants any user a decisive
advantage in a world that is filled with
challenges and dangers these fantastic
and sometimes quite bizarre powers do
not only create amazing fights and
battles but they also open up a world to
us that seems to be full of unlimited
possibilities no matter if it's ice fire
dragons or bubbles each fruit has its
own unique design and skill set but what
if there were actually devil fruits with
powers related to themselves what if you
could actually steal devil fruits or
nullify them and where have we already
seen hints at this in the story the
concept i'm talking about here are me
the devil fruits but before we can
actually go and discuss potential meter
powers in the one piece world we first
have to understand what a media devil
fruit actually is so first let's have a
quick look at the concept of devil
fruits and what the term meda actually
means in this context devil fruits are a
central part of the power system in one
piece they are in a way the speciality
of the series in contrast to other power
systems like for example the chakra and
jutsu system in naruto while it is
unknown where they originated from the
fruits are said to be incarnations of
the sea devil himself and as a result
their users lose the ability to swim
since they're from now on considered to
be hated by the sea
stored inside every fruit is a unique
power that is transferred to the very
first person animal or even object that
consumes any part of it with a possible
exception of blackbeard it is not
possible to eat more than one devil
fruit during one's lifetime and if you
would it would swiftly lead to the death
of the consumer the powers granted by
those fruits can be divided into three
distinct categories the zone type can be
translated as the animal type these
devil fruits allow the user to turn
their bodies into fully or partly
developed animals
logia fruit wielders are referred to as
the natural type they are granted the
powers over natural elements this does
not only give them power over it but
also allows them to alter their body
into the very same element making them
immune to most physical attacks the last
known category belongs to the so-called
paramecia users which translated means
something like superhuman while these
fruits definitely grant the user's
superhuman abilities this category also
includes pretty much all those fruits
that don't really fit into the other two
now these three categories together
describe all types of devil fruits we
have encountered so far over the course
of the entire story kaido can turn into
a dragon aokiji can turn into ice and
katakuri loves donuts oh yeah and he
also can control mochi of course but
what would meta actually mean in this
context
meter powers are a concept that is often
misunderstood in many fandoms since it
can be a little bit difficult to wrap
your head around it when you go on
different forums or other discussion
platforms people often refer to the term
meta when it comes to powers like time
travel resurrection instant wind skills
or changing fate while all of these
concepts are without a doubt very
powerful and are usually out of the
ordinary none of these powers can
actually be described as meter because
what the word meter really means is
something that either refers to itself
or is self-referential in regard to a
story this would describe a power that
is able to affect the medium at work so
since the power system we are discussing
in regard to one piece are devil fruits
the term meat in this regard would refer
to powers affecting this very same power
system now while this might sound a
little bit confusing it is actually
pretty simple when you put it in another
way meter devil fruits have the power to
affect other devil fruits now what this
means is that the reference point for
such a fruit would not be an animal an
element or any superhuman ability but
the very source of exactly these powers
this would make them decisively
different from the three established
types and therefore would have to be put
in a fourth category namely media devil
fruits the purpose of these fruits would
be to have a countermeasure against
other devil fruit users while there
actually are natural weaknesses to devil
fruit powers in the world namely
seawater and sea prism stone they often
only work incompletely and only work to
render the one touched by them immobile
meter powers however would allow the
users to actually interact and affect
these powers
now at this point you might already
think that the introduction of such a
concept is pretty unthinkable for one
piece but before we can get into the
pros and cons of having such powers in
the universe let's first have a look at
some examples of potential fruits to get
a better understanding of what we're
really talking about here now for every
fruit i'm going to present to you i will
firstly state that powers and then we'll
give like a short description of what
this power might actually look like in
the story this will simply be a
presentation of how i personally see the
fruit in my head but obviously these
powers could all be incorporated into
the story completely differently so if
you say ohara i think this power would
look completely differently put it in
the comments below and let's discuss it
there to warm up i want to start with a
relatively simple power copying other
people's devil fruits i'm actually a
little bit surprised we haven't really
seen this concept yet in the story the
idea behind this is that the wielder of
the let's call it copy copy know me can
copy the ability of his opponent while
this might work in a few different ways
i like to think that it would require
some sort of action to activate this
power a possible prerequisite could for
example be having to touch your opponent
together with a certain time limit i
would see this fruit strength rather
outside of battle since copying
someone's power does not grant you their
experience with the ability so copying
luffy's rubber power would most likely
not allow you to compete with luffy on
his level since he had years to own his
skills with the fruit it would much
rather be useful if it were used in
stealth so you could use the copy power
for any other purpose open battle with
the media fruit against the person you
got the power from would in my mind only
be able for someone who has the wits to
understand and analyze any fruit quickly
and then immediately come up with
creative ideas on how to use them
nonetheless i think it would make for
some more than interesting battles if
this power really existed in the story
the next potential fruit that i really
want to discuss is the ability to
enhance other people's powers in essence
it would be the power to affect someone
else's devil fruit and make it stronger
or more effective again i think this
would require some limitations like a
time limit or a limit to the degree of
improvement still i think this would
make an amazing concept for a character
that has a supporting role in battle
with this you could for example increase
the magnitude of loki or paramecia users
and give more strength or additional
forms to zone types all in all i think
it would make for very interesting meter
power in the context of tactical and
strategic battles
nexon a smaller and less powerful but
nonetheless very useful power would be
the power to identify other devil fruit
users now while this would give you very
little to no advantage on a physical
level it would allow you to identify who
in the enemy's group uses a devil fruit
and maybe even which one this would in
my mind require fewer prerequisites
since the power is mostly based on
information still it would be a very
useful asset to any pirate or marine
crew especially in the grand line that
is full of devil fruit users with
unknown abilities
another potential meter power would be
the ability to transfer devil fruit
powers from one person to another
compared to the fruit identification
power this could actually be used in
battle very well transferring the power
of an opponent onto one of your own
cameras would not only weaken the
opponent but at the same time strengthen
your side you could also lend the power
of someone who has become unable to
fight to someone else in that way i
would also rather see it in a supporting
corner but it definitely would have
great potential in actual battle as well
the meter fruit i'm going to present you
now i would consider to be the most
powerful of all but at the same time i
don't think we'll actually see it in the
story the ultimate meter power in regard
to devil fruits would of course be the
creation of new devil fruits this would
grant the user such unbelievable power
that it would make it too plot
inconvenient and ridiculously
overpowered to be a normal power the
only way this could be integrated in
some form into the story would be to tax
its use with heavy restrictions or
limits funnily enough though there is a
theory out there some of you might have
heard of that proposes that the one
piece itself is in fact such a master
devil fruit and that goldie roger ate it
the theory goes on to state that the
fruit brought with it a curse that
transformed the soul of anyone that
roger killed into a new devil fruit now
while i'll personally do not like this
theory very much it would actually
integrate this power creation devil
fruit into the story
now lastly to round this up let's talk a
little bit about two relatively simple
but at the same time very relevant types
of media devil fruits
the first one i'm talking about here is
the power to steal powers this means
that a user of let's call it the steel
steel fruit would be able to take other
people's devil free powers from them now
this could play out in very different
ways you could steal someone's power
temporarily or indefinitely you could
steal it and acquire the power yourself
or you could simply rob the powers from
its user and then put it back into a new
fruit
now i think some of you have already
rang a bell at this point because the
power actually does exist in the story
already for some reasons we don't know
the blackbeard pirates are actually able
to steal devil fruits from their users
now while it's widely speculated that
this is not as much an individual power
than a method of extraction we still
cannot exclude the possibility that
there exists such a devil fruit out
there that grants this power maybe not
to blackbeard himself but to someone
else now the last power that i want to
introduce is the power to nullify devil
fruit powers this would not mean taking
their pals from them but simply robbing
them of the ability to use them and once
again this power has actually been shown
in the story before and once again
blackbeard was involved his yami yami
nomi seems to be capable of exactly this
meat of power it allows blackbeard to
drain any one of their abilities by
simply touching them all devil fruits
beat paramecia zone or logia seem to be
affected by this additionally unlike
seawater sea prism stone or armament
haki his nullification of devil fruit
powers truly seems to be absolute it
works as though devil fruit users had
never gained their powers in the first
place additionally the yami yami nomi is
also considered to be unique even within
the logia type so this fruit is actually
my strongest evidence for there actually
being meter powers in one piece it might
be a hint that there is actually a
fourth devil fruit category in the world
after all if you now ask yourself
whether such a fruit category wouldn't
be too overpowered compared to the
others consider this over the course of
the story for a long time we believed
that low-gear users had an incredibly
unfair advantage over the other
categories by simply being unable to be
touched while at the same time being
able to control the elements they wield
only with the introduction of haki did
logia users to a certain extent fall in
reputation behind the paramecia types
with introduction of the likes of
doflamingo big mom and katakuri wielding
incredible powers this was also
emphasized by oda by introducing karibu
and caesar into the story after the time
skip they are seen as kind of weakish
and comedy characters comparable to
buggy before the time skip and now
having finally arrived in wano people
start murmuring whether zone type users
might not actually be the strongest of
out of the three so if we now were to be
introduced to a fourth category of devil
fruit a media type of fruit it would
very likely be considered to be the
strongest but what this example actually
shows is that the power of the different
devil fruit types actually rather
depends on the power level and
intelligence of the user on top of that
every fruit type as well as every
individual devil fruit is subject to
certain weaknesses that come with its
power lightning is weak to rubber rubber
is weak to swords swords are weak to
zorro and zorro is weak to geography but
that's beside the point the point is
that at a certain level the type of the
fruit you use becomes less significant
while physical strength willpower
intelligence and personal experience
become exponentially more important
this would obviously also apply for me
to double fruits while their power would
without a doubt be incredibly strong
they would also be very situation
specific since they would only be able
to target other devil fruit users also
each power would have to include certain
conditions or prerequisites that would
come with them as can be seen in many
other devil fruits this may for example
be a time limit a limit to the amount of
usages a range limit or even a limit to
the user's health this kind of nerfing
would be necessary to ensure that media
devil fruits could fit in together with
all the other three types now if media
devil fruits actually existed in one
piece where would they be and who would
use them as we discussed before
blackbeard might very well be considered
as a kind of media fruit user already
due to his nullification powers
regarding other types of the media
category we have to consider that many
of the strongest characters haven't
actually been revealed yet we still have
close to no information about the powers
of two entire yonko crews as well as big
parts of kaido's crew additionally we
have the revolutionaries the marines and
former old pirates that we do not know
much about what are green balls powers
and what are the powers of the roger
pirates one entity that in my mind is
the most likely to be possession of such
powers would be the world government or
rather the gorosei and imsamar due to
their battle scars we can expect the
gorosei to actually be experienced in
battle and also im summa will most
likely have some sort of devil fruit
ability now since the world government
will most likely have hoarded the
strongest devil fruits to keep in use
for themselves media devil fruits would
be the ideal choice to deal with the
biggest threats to their reign